-Naissance de la télévision
3e chaîne, première fois.
[Musique d'intro.]
...
Voilà.
Est-ce que c'est la 3e chaîne
juste avant la 3e chaîne ?
-C'est peux de chose,
finalement.
-C'est rien du tout.
-Rien du tout.
-Rien que les ondes de M. Hertz
et de M. Maxwell qui court partout.
Mais on ne les voient pas.
Ca ne vous fait pas peur cette
3e chaîne privée de 3e chaîne ?
-Si, bien sûr. C'est peut-être
le moment le plus exaltant..
..de son histoire.
Aucune déception,
aucun faux pas, pas de critique,
..pas l'ombre d'un téléspectateur.
-Ce téléspectateur là serait
un ingrat, car en janvier..
..il a versé pour 2 chaînes, et
on lui en donne une 3e en décembre.
-Pour l'instant, c'est le paradis,
c'est la béatitude.
-On ne va pas rester dans
la béatitude jusqu'à demain !
-Il faut meubler ce froid décor.
Mur !
-Apprenti sorcier, dis donc !
Je vais essayer. Sol !
C'est amusant, hein ?
-Oui.
Spot !
-Ca va mieux, hein ?
-On se sent vraiment chez soi.
Rien ne manque.
-Indispensable.
C'est quoi ce poisson rouge ?
-Ca, c'est pour les interludes.
-Ah bon ?
-Oui.
-Aucun doute, on est vraiment
sur une chaîne de télévision.
Mais quelque chose me tracasse.
Ceux qui viennent d'allumer leur
poste ignorent ce qu'ils regardent.
-C'est vrai.
-Certains s'imaginent sur la 1re.
-Quelle horreur !
-Si on reprenait l'ouverture ?
-Vous avez raison. Mire !
-Naissance de la 3e chaîne
de télévision, 2e fois.
-Vous ne trouvez pas que cette 3e
chaîne ressemble aux 2 premières ?
-Vous avez raison.
Il manque 2 choses :
..le champagne et la marraine.
-Ah, la marraine !
Mais c'est très délicat.
-Et le champagne, alors ?
-C'est la marraine
la plus importante.
-Comment vous la voyez
la marraine de la 3e chaîne ?
-Je ne sais pas.
Je la vois charmante, piquante...
Ce n'est pas ça du tout.
-Ah bon ?
-Pas du tout !
-Alors, je recommence.
-Oui, c'est mieux. C'est mieux.
Déjà vue sur les autres chaînes.
-Ah bon ?
-Oui.
-Je vais me concentrer...
-Non ! Moi.
-C'est Anne-Marie David !
-Oui.
-C'est la marraine ?
Bonsoir, Anne-Marie David.
-Bonsoir à tous.
-Quel cadeau apportez-vous ?
-Une chanson qui naîtra ce soir
comme la 3e chaîne.
-Qu'en pensez-vous ?
-Je n'aurais pas mieux fait.
...
-C'est à deux.
C'est quand même à deux.
C'est quand même à deux..
..qu'on est le plus heureux.
A deux.
C'est quand même à deux..
..qu'on est mieux.
Le matin,
en ouvrant les yeux,
..on entend au loin..
..celui qu'on aime,
..qui va, qui vient.
Tout un jour à deux,
qu'on est bien.
Le courrier,
..on y répondra.
Mais plus tard.
Les copains,
..on les reverras.
Pas ce soir.
On s'embrasse,
on bavarde un peu.
On met la télé.
On dîne au coin du feu.
On danse.
On oublie le temps.
Mais soudain,
sans savoir comment,
..on s'aime.
On s'aime.
[Elle tient la note.]
C'est merveilleux.
...
C'est quand même à deux.
A deux, mains dans la main.
Tu sais,
c'est quand même à deux..
..qu'on est bien.
Car l'amour, tu y penses aussi.
Je le crois.
C'est ta force
d'être deux, un jour.
On est trois.
Et pourtant,
..lorsque vient le temps,
..le temps des adieux,
..le temps des cheveux blancs,
..tu sais,
quand on devient vieux,
..c'est à deux.
C'est à deux.
C'est... à deux.
C'est à deux, c'est à deux,
c'est à deux, c'est...
à deux.
C'est à deux.
A deux.
A... deux.
C'est à deux.
...
-Chère marraine, voulez-vous
baptiser notre 3e chaîne ?
-Comment cela ?
-C'est très simple.
En vous saisissant de cette
bouteille de champagne,
..et on la brisant
sur cette mire symbolique.
-Que vas-t-il se passer après ?
-Notre chaîne sera baptisée
officiellement 3e du nom.
-Tout est prêt derrière ?
-Bien sûr.
Quelle question !
-Ce n'était pas prêt !
C'est toujours pareil !
Regardez-moi ce gâchis !
Il va falloir balayer tout ça.
-Ca commence mal.
-Excusez-le,
..M. le directeur.
-Pour moi,
le champagne est déjà frappé.
-Excusez-le, M. le général...
euh, directeur général.
-Il est général ?
-Non, directeur général.
On dit un directeur général
et pas l'inverse.
-Et alors ?
-Il est en civile.
Mais ce n'est pas un militaire.
-Alors pourquoi "général" ?
-J'ai dis ça..
..comme j'aurais dit "particulier".
-Il est particulier ?
-Non, "particulier"
comme on dit "général".
-Finalement, on dit quoi ?
-M. les directeurs généraux.
-Ca se fait, en général ?
-Directeur ou général,
ils ont bien dit.
Moi, si j'avais..
..affaire à un discours,
je ne serais que dire.
-Mais si !
-Je ne suis pas jaloux.
Chacun à sa spécialité.
Et peut-être
qu'ils ne savent pas balayer.
On peut être tranquilles,
..ce sont des petits comme nous
qui tenons la 3e chaîne.
Si je balaie les ondes..
..et la chaîne,
que reste-t-il ?
-Si on était..
..musiciens, on la tiendrait ?
-Pareil.
[Il joue maladroitement
le violon.]
...
-Que faites-vous ?
-Je pense.
-Je peux continuer ?
-Bien sûr.
-A quoi pensez-vous ?
-Que je n'ai pas envie de jouer.
Tout à l'heure,
au moment du solo de violon,
..on verra qu'on entendra rien.
-Désolé de vous décevoir,
..il n'y a pas de solo de violon.
-Mais de trombone.
-C'est quoi le rapport ?
-Le type m'a prêté
ce violon avec mon trombone.
Au moment du solo de trombone,
il sera paumé.
-Il joue quoi ?
-De la clarinette.
-A qui appartient ce violon ?
-Au joueur de basse.
-Le violoniste a prêté son
violon au clarinettiste a qui..
..vous avez donné votre trombone.
-Le bassiste ne joue pas de violon.
-Pourquoi ces échanges ce soir ?
-Pour montrer que c'est nous..
..qui tenons la 3e chaîne.
Si on était danseurs,
..on la tiendrait la 3e chaîne ?
-Pareil.
-On va travailler ton évasion.
-Mais maître !
-Pas de "mais" ! C'est
l'inauguration de la 3e chaîne,
..il faut réussir ton évasion.
-Pourquoi vous me parlez ainsi ?
-Pour prouver que sans les danseurs,
la télé serait de la radio.
1, 2, 6, 12 !
Il est bien mon sujet ! Du jamais
vu sur les autres chaînes.
-Je veux redescendre !
Je veux redescendre !
-Et si on était pompiers ?
-Pareil !
-J'aime ce métier, et vous ?
[Il répète.]
-Perroquet !
-Quoi ?
-Vous êtes sourd ?
-Qu'avez-vous dit ?
-"J'aime ce métier".
-Je viens de vous le dire.
-Pourquoi vous aimez votre métier ?
-C'est un métier noble.
Et c'est un métier dans..
..lequel on vit
sur une grande échelle.
On est..
..utiles à la télévision.
-Pas question..
..de monter..
.."Jeanne au bûcher".
-"La danse du feu",
"Les femmes savantes".
-Pas de film fumant.
-Vous avez du feu ?
-Vous fumez encore ?
-Je suis tout feu,
tout flamme ! Si on était..
..cameramans ?
-Pareil ! Je le suis, car à l'école,
..j'étais sage comme une image.
-Ca a été mon but. Ulysse a été..
..bercé par les champs
des sirènes, moi les champs..
..des caméras.
-Le gros plan, ça me connait.
-Moi,
je hais le plan général.
-Sans cameraman,
pas de caméra.
-Sans caméra, pas de télé.
-Sans télé, pas de..
..3e chaîne.
-Ni de 2e ni de 1re.
-Sans nous,
on serait absents.
-Et pas de soirée inaugurale.
Silence, on tourne !
-Et si on était preneur de son ?
-Pareil ! On la tiendrait comme ça.
-Nous le sont la 3e chaîne.
Sans preneur de son, on ne
pourrait pas prendre le son.
-Et sans son ?
-On serait au temps du cinéma muet.
-Il y avait l'image.
-Une image sans son,
c'est comme un marin sans bateau,
..un trapéziste sans trapèze...
-Un pain sans farine de son.
C'est une image.
-Trouves-en une autre.
-Un pêcheur sans poisson.
-Belle image ! Prenez ça.
-Mais c'est grâce à vous.
-Pourquoi ?
-Vous m'avez
tendu la perche.
-Et si on était...
-Vous allez
nous faire virer !
[Musique.]
...
-Vous regardez quoi ?
-Mes photos,
en souvenir de cette journée.
-Vous en avez combien ?
-Deux.
-C'est M. Guillaud,
notre directeur.
-Sur son landeau.
-M. Arthur Conte avec..
..ses trois filles. Les deux 1res
sont déjà des chefs-d'oeuvres.
Les tarifs augmentent ?
-J'espère.
Un 3e enfant, c'est important.
-Surtout quand il y a eu 2.
-Forcément,
sinon ce serait la 1re.
-Et on ne fêterait pas la 3e.
-Le trois est important.
-Oui, c'est un chiffre sacré.
-Il y a les sept péchés capitaux...
-Non, non, non !
Pourquoi citez-vous le sept ?
-C'est aussi
un nombre sacré.
-Oui. Selon les jeunes chimistes
et les théosophes, ils codifient..
..l'harmonie universelle.
Et on le retrouve souvent..
..dans l'énumération importante.
-Les douze Apôtres, par exemple.
-Les douze coups de minuit.
-"J'ai fait ça en douze".
-Connaissez-vous la définition
du trois en 7 volumes ?
-1 + 2.
-Non, 2 + 1.
-On a créé les deux premières
chaînes pour faire patienter..
..les téléspectateurs de la 3e ?
-Nous n'irons pas jusque là.
Mais depuis
la naissance du monde,
..le trois a toujours
été remarquable.
-Des exemples ! Des exemples !
-Oui, oui ! Bien sûr.
Par exemple,
la règle de trois.
-Le cinq à sept.
-C'est quoi le rapport ?
-Le trois vient troubler
le 5 à 7 des deux.
-Et dans l'histoire, on rencontre
très souvent le chiffre trois.
Par exemple, les trois fils
de Noé, les trois rois mages,
..les Trois-Evêchés...
-"Tess tous les verdins".
-"Metz".
-Dans le désordre, comme le tiercé.
-On parle d'histoire.
-Le cheval de Troie,
..c'est quoi ?
-De l'histoire.
"Les Trois Mousquetaires".
-Qui étaient 4.
-Mais 3 + 1.
En Savoie, les Trois-Vallées.
-Au Canada, les Trois-Rivières.
-Les Trois-Epis, en France.
-Détroit de Gibraltar.
-Oh non !
-Au cinéma, "Le troisième homme"...
-"Les 39 Marches".
-C'est pas trois !
-3 et 9 qui est un multiple de 3,
..3 x 3 font 9.
Vous avez trois 3,
..un trois qui précède,
ce qui fait 4 x 3.
-Et 4 x 12, comme les 12 mois.
-Revenons au trois.
-En marine, le trois-mâts.
-En vrac, "Les trois orfèvres",
.."Les trois valses",
"Les trois pyramides".
-"Les trois sergents de la
Rochelle", quand le 4e est en perme.
-Et les personnages historiques
marqués par le trois,
..ils sont beaucoup.
-Richard III, Napoléon III.
-Duguay-Trouin.
-"Trou".
-Vous jouez en golfe ?
-Non, "Duguay-Trouin".
-Quel rapport avec le trois ?
-On enchaîne. Alexandre III.
-On l'enchaîne ?
-On le cite.
Il a fait le pont.
-Paul III
a fait bien des choses.
Et Pie III, rien du tout.
-Ministre à l'esprit étroit.